ladies and
gentlemen the
entertainment the much celebrated Dr
Jack
[Applause]
[Music]
Dawkins you must be the doctor everyone
speaks so fondly of I was not born into
a life of wealth I do not have the
luxury of be able to cause trouble and
get away with
it hello doch what the hell are you
doing here F do they hang escaped
convicts
here this isn't London Jack there's
nowhere to hide if I don't come up with
a Year's worth of income I get my hand
chopped off which one my choice well
there
something I'm not going back to thie bck
pocketing you used to live
[Music]
pretty I've come here to train hes
this is all I could find in a
hurry One Last
Time Now ladies and gentlemen can we
Rouse him from Living
[Music]
death now that would
require
[Music]
artfulness